un nouveau combat politique pour valérie
froberger l'aide soignante responsable
syndical et militante communiste est
candidate dans la 12e circonscription
thibault langlois comme suppléant pour
cette législative partielle ou la france
insoumise et le parti communiste parti
allié une campagne tournée vers la
défense des services publics le climat
ainsi que l'urgence sociale et
économique
pendant la période du confinement on a
bien on a bien vu que les petites
entreprises les petites associations les
coopératives ont terriblement souffert
et ont été fragilisés pendant cette
période
et malheureusement elles n'ont pas reçu
une aide de l'état et donc service à les
amener en grande difficulté des
difficultés attendent que la candidate
est venu recueillir sur le terrain
vendredi 11 septembre près de plusieurs
acteurs et associations locales une
visite accompagné de la députée de la
france insoumise danièle obono
aujourd'hui via besoin d'avoir à
l'assemblée nationale des élus des
parlementaires qui mène une bataille
acharnée pour répondre aux besoins de la
situation on est en pleine crise
sanitaire encore et la crise économique
et sociale qui est en cours pour autant
la gauche ne fera pas front commun à
l'élection la conseillère régionale et
première adjointe de trappes sandrine
grand gang part de son côté pour
génération et europe ecologie les verts
on est vrai pour le rassemblement des
forces de gauche territoire en
organisant à notre initiative presseur
réunions et de discussions on trouve
tout simplement regrettable qu'on n'ait
pas pu se mettre à trouver un accord
valérie froberger se dit encore ouverte
aux discussions pour un éventuel
rassemblement face aux deux candidatures
de gauche neuf autres sont en lice pour
cette législative partielle